southern nevada dads are stepping up to
keep our schools safe thank you for
joining us i'm brian loftis and i'm
denise valdez the eight news now i-team
in fact first introduced you to dads in
schools which is a volunteer program
aimed at supporting students and
deterring violence and tonight ccsd
approving a partnership with that
organization sasha loftis joins us live
now with more
denise and brian a lot of parents
students and teachers stood up tonight
in support of the dads in schools
program they called a creative solution
to what they call an ongoing and
frightening issue in schools
lately it has been a war zone strong
words from parents students and teachers
as they plead for an end to school
violence why should i be filled with
fear every time i hear the crackle of
the intercom after a series of
concerning issues at desert oasis high
school and around the clark county
school district in the last few weeks
many say they need to see change now it
just breaks your heart to see
what the staff is going through and the
students troy martinez believes dads in
schools is the answer the program which
ccsc trustees approved a collaboration
with thursday brings volunteers many who
are also dads onto campuses to walk the
halls and support students just having
the sheer presence of male role models
on campus prevents violence fights
and other behavior that's you know
difficult for for the staff provide
prevention to presence martinez says the
dads will also help teachers promote
safety and many call it a step in the
right direction the presence of dads and
hallways is positively positively
interacting with students has proven to
be a deterrent to misbehavior so kids
can focus on enjoying their education
without fear something needs to change
as of yesterday
not everyone was on board with it with
this rather the i-team has heard from
someone who says they're concerned about
unlicensed volunteers being on campus
now the dads in schools initiative
starts tomorrow march 25th and is set to
run through june 30 of next year
reporting live tonight sasha loftis live
local now